the total number of people that we
allowed in from Syria genuine refugees
last year I I have to say I think was
pitifully small there are persecuted
minorities in Syria and I I think
there's a case for saying that if we had
proper control over immigration policy
if we had a an Australian type system
immigration and we could democratically
decide how many people we we allow in
then there's a very strong argument to
say that actually we should allow in
more genuine political refugees I think
we could work with agencies
nongovernmental organizations in in
Turkey and find persecuted minorities
who genuinely fear for their their
future and I think we could we could
certainly be more generous if I may say
last year we accepted as a country
12,000 people for political asylum
that's a tiny tiny number the the
overall number of net immigration into
this country was 330 thousand I would
like us to have in an immigration system
where we could say yes to people
genuinely fleeing persecution but but
but no to people with criminal records
from from from the EU yeah I just want
to talk about those net migration
figures now you've brought them up they
are at a record high do you think the
government is doing enough to tackle it
I mean clearly they're not they're you
know not meeting their own targets but
they're targeting people like students
and unskilled workers are they really
the kind of people they should be
targeting in terms of dealing with this
problem I think the government the most
charitable thing I can say about
ministers is that they're clueless the
minister said he was disappointed using
the sort of the tone and the manner of a
perhaps a vicar explaining why the
village fete had been cancelled I mean
II it's not disappointing it's it's
shocking a basic a function of
government is to control who comes in
and this government is is not up to the
job of doing that
now which is what's that call the
immigration issue then because as it
stands the figures are high how would
you get that down how would you tackle
it we cannot continue to have the free
movement of people we cannot continue to
allow nearly half a billion people from
the EU
traumatic right to come here this is
about fairness there are in my
constituency first and second generation
Britons who deeply resent the fact that
they can't bring ante over to this
country for a wedding and at the same
time we see people from the EU coming
into this country and there's nothing we
can do to say yes or no regardless of
whether they've got a criminal record or
not surely it's not a fair system of
immigration that says no to a computer
programmer from India but yes to someone
with a criminal record from the EU we
need a system like in Australia where
every year Parliament would vote on the
total number of visas to be issued we
could then have a constructive debate
about the skills we need and yes I would
be prepared to stand up in the House of
Commons and say you know what we need to
extend a bit of humanitarian aid to a
few genuine refugees from Syria and give
them genuine asylum and you know what if
we had democratic control over
immigration and the Australian system I
think people would buy that